hey guys this is andrew from
tradingsensors.com so
i've been working as a professional
trainer for the past six years in hong
kong
and i'm doing right now some youtube
videos for around three months because
guys i want to show you how protraders
are working the different tools and
techniques that we use at least
those that work for me so if you want to
know about all this stuff and if you
want to know how we actually make money
on the market
you are in the right place so today i
want to make an analysis on
the oil market because the old market is
actually a very good indicator for the
equity market
let's get into it
[Music]
so this is the oil market for the past
10 years
the trend looks bearish definitely but
something very interesting is happening
here guys so
this is when the oil so this is the
coverage crisis of course the oil was
turning negatively and since then we
have a rebound we are trading above the
200
moving average on the weekly time frame
which is bullish
but we are confronted to a major
resistance i don't know if you guys
spotted it to me it's kind of
obvious i just you know connect the
highs that i had during the past 10
years on the weekly time frame
and you can see that it's working pretty
well one two
three almost four and you can see that
this is
actually the level where we had uh so
let me go to a daily time frame
63. this is the level where we got
rejected guys
we got rejected here and we lost five
percent
how funny how funny that a 10 year
trend is giving you that precise signals
this one is obvious and everybody saw it
and every old trader
had some profit taking at 62 63 guys
because they are professionals and
they know how the market is behaving and
if everybody
makes the same thing it becomes a
self-fulfilling prophecy
and this is exactly exactly what
happened here we we are still trading
above the moving averages
so this move is to me intact and
we are actually checking if we're going
to have a breakout right away
once again guys i did a video very
interesting i think for you to watch
on uh the nasdaq bubble that is
happening right now
and on the s p 500 bubble that is not
happening yet but happening soon this is
my view
and i was saying that you need to follow
the oil the dxy
the 10-year yield as indicators and
to show you if yes or not the bubble is
happening so guys if we have a breakout
here
this means that we are in a situation
where this bubble is likely to happen
and this is confirming my scenario that
the equity market is gonna take
maybe a hundred percent in one year so
i'm gonna be very careful
on this one and i'm gonna use it to
actually build my views
on the equity market so for now we
are bullish but we didn't have the
breakout
yet so keep an eye on this one that's it
for me i hope you guys enjoyed this
video
i hope this um is gonna help you to
understand that you know some long-term
actually analysis
can be very efficient on the short term
and if you guys enjoyed this video
please don't forget to click the sub
like and bell button
so you're going to be the first to know
when i upload anything new and stay
close to show
i'll see you guys